thousands of parents are expected to
take to the streets across the UK
calling for government reforms to child
care and parental leave joining me now
is Sky's Sadia Chaudhary she's in
Trafalgar Square for us this morning uh
morning Sadia it's looking busy there
behind you what specifically are people
calling for
well they want government reform of this
sector and this is a nationwide protest
we're at the protest here in London and
if you speak to the mums and dads here
you'll get some Grim statistics from
them about the state of the sector right
now they say 54 000 women have to leave
their careers every year because of
child care issues I'm just going to go
over now and speak to Benazir Yani who
joins us today thank you very much for
speaking to us just talk to me about
what brings you here today so we're here
for three reasons today one is we want
affordable quality child care we would
like ring fence posts for paternity or
paternity leave we want people who we
want properly paid to paternity leave
and then lastly we won
um flexible working as a default for
everyone you were talking to me earlier
about the impact it's had on your career
just talk to me about that well it's
quite stressful you can't do anything
last minute I don't think people
appreciate just how much it takes to get
someone you know with a child to work
especially when you're having to travel
in it takes a lot of preparation
beforehand and then when you're invited
to last minute meetings outside of work
you know 6 30 you just can't attend them
and you just end up feeling really bad
you feel like you look bad against your
counterparts who all can attend
and it doesn't put you off having more
children it does it makes you feel like
um that maybe maybe one you can handle
but two it would just be it would just
be too much in terms of child care as
well it makes you feel like you can't
really have a career because it's just
not cost it does not cost yeah it
doesn't work out
um so so yeah you feel like maybe if I
didn't have the support that I had in
terms of them you know grandparents
around
um I don't know how I would work just
generally speaking so I don't know how
people without grandparents and parents
kind of support them go back into the
workplace and what are your specific
demands what do you want to see change
I would like to not not be made to feel
bad
um for wanting to work I want to and the
only way that that can happen is if
flexible working is something that is
offered to everyone
um and I think as well you know the
child care is is a really
um it's a massive factor in deciding
whether or not you can have a career as
a as a woman as a mother
um and if you know we're 50 of the
workforce and we really should be like
you know made it should be made a
priority by now this is Anne Forrest who
joins me now so thank you so much for
speaking to us tell us about why you're
here today well it's just uh ever since
having the kids it's just uh it's it's
so surprisingly expensive to um put them
into well I have to we both have to work
um my partner's actually working today
because we can't we're struggling to
make ends meet
um the cost of Nursery is is we've got
two kids of three and five and uh even
even just holiday clubs you know don't
get as much all that much time off
um so I'm just sort of having to pay
other people to look after my children
and they're doing a great job but it's
costing you know more than our mortgage
um every month you know it's it's just a
real struggle and it just feels a bit
unfair I'm just going to explain to our
viewers why you're dressed like this
because this is a Halloween themed March
from mummy's uh Proto I'm very literally
a mummy
and just talk to us about how being a
mum has impacted your career
um well it's just a lot of juggling like
I'm just
constantly feeling like I'm not giving
my children enough not giving my work
enough and it's quite it's it's just
it's just you're always in the middle
you know you're always just trying to
make it work and we and we're doing all
right but we're you know it's it It's
just tough and by your demands what
would what would what needs to change to
help you out I think I think childcare
should be subsidized um I think
um but it's not like people in nurse
that work in nurseries they're getting
paid very well but
um so there must be a way of just
helping helping parents uh be able to to
work if they want to or maybe give them
the choice you know we didn't I didn't
have a choice as to whether to go back
to work or not I had to because we had
to we have to pay we had we needed two
incomes to be able to um pay our
mortgage and look after the children so
um yeah and I think flexible working is
really important for working parents
mums and dads
um luckily my my work are quite good at
being quite flexible but I know a lot of
places aren't and actually because since
the pandemic they've really um okay it's
all the Technologies in place now we're
also used to being able to work from
home and it's made a massive difference
and I just want that to keep going you
know I think it's really important that
they they allow us to choose you know
whether to work from home or in the
office and just just help us with the
juggle a little bit you know I don't
think it's that much to ask excellent
and Forrest thank you so much for
speaking to us well this is a story that
we're hearing time and time again from
people here and as you can see it is a
Halloween themed protest many people in
costumes for this and they want the
government to step in to reform the
sector because they say it is in a
complete mess
you don't care all right so Sadia thank
you very much in D